نعم محمد هي في الحقيقه سلسله من الغارات
الجويه الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت عددا من
المنازل في مناطق متفرقه من مدينه خانيونس
قبل قليل ابرز واعنف هذه الغارات هي غاره
جويه بعدد من الصواريخ استهدفت مربعا
سكنيا في منطقه قيزان النجار جنوب مدينه
خانيونس ادت هذه الغاره حتى هذه اللحظه
الى استشهاد 13 فلسطينيا بينهم خمس اطفال
بالاضافه الى وصول عشرات الاصابات الى
مجمع ناصر الطبي هنا في خانيونس بعض
الاصابات بحسب المصادر الطبيه في المجمع
هي اصابات بالغه الخطوره وان عدد الشهداء
مرشح للارتفاع بالاضافه الى منزل استهدفته
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه قرب الحي
النمساوي في محيط مجمع ناصر نقلت طواقم
الاسعاف الى مجمع ناصر عشرات الاصابات
جلهم من الاطفال والنساء نتيجه استهداف
هذا المنزل منذ ساعات الصباح وحتى هذه
اللحظه ارتفع عدد الشهداء في مدينه
خانيونس الى 21 شهيدا نتيجه تواصل الغارات
الجويه وايضا القصف المدفعي الكثيف من قبل
الدبابات الاسرائيليه على مختلف المناطق
في مدينه خانيونس بالتزامن مع تواصل
الاشتباكات في عدد من المحاور في المدينه
ابرزها محور المحطه وايضا الكتيبه وشارع
خمسه بالاضافه الى المحاور المشتعله منذ
ايام في منطقه خزاعه وعبس وبني سهيله وسط
محاولات
اسرائيليه للتقدم الى وسط مدينه خان يونس
بغطاء جوي وايضا مدفعي من قبل الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه كتائب القسام ظهر
اليوم اعلنت عن استهداف تجمعين للاليات
وايضا لجنود جيش الاحتلال في مدينه
خانيونس بعشرات من قذائف الهون الوضع
الصحي هنا في في مجمع ناصر الطبي هو وضع
صعب وماسا وي للغايه نتيجه توافد الاعداد
الكبيره من المصابين الذين بينهم مصابون
بجروح خطيره جدا بحاجه لاجراء عمليات
معقده وسط امكانيات بسيطه ومحدوده لدى
المستشفى وايضا نقص في الكوادر الطبيه
امام الاعداد الكبيره من الاصابات التي
تصل على مدار الساعه من مدينه خان يونس
نتيجه استمرار القصف والغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه على مدار ايام وحتى هذه
اللحظه اذا القصف الذي كنا نتابعه مؤمن
قبل قليل اثناء مرور وائل في محيط
المستشفى كما افدتنا ارتفع الى حصيله هذا
القصف ارتفع الى 13 شهيدا منهم خمسه اطفال
وهنا يعني نذكر معك بالمناطق التي تستهدف
في محيط مستشفى ناصر على مدار الايام
الماضيه ايضا كان مستشفى الامل ومحيط
ايضا مسرحا لعده قذائف مدفعيه فما هي
المناطق التي تستهدف في المناطق المجاوره
والقريبه منكم في في قلب مدينه خانيونس
ومحيط
[موسيقى]
المستشفيات نعم محمد في الحي النمساوي
القريب من مستشفى ناصر وايضا من المستشفى
الميداني الاردني كان عرضه لقصف اسرائيلي
قبل قليل بالاضافه الى بلوك 112 او ما
يعرف مخيم خانيونس وهو متاخم للجدار
الغربي لمجمع ناصر منذ ايام طلب جيش
الاحتلال من سكان هذه المنطقه الاخلاء
ويواصل القصف المدفع والغارات الجويه على
هذه المنطقه وايضا سبق خلال الايام
السابقه غارتين من الطائرات الحربيه وايضا
بالقصف المدفعي من الدبابات لمحيط مستشفى
الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر في
خانيونس وادت هذه الق قصف وهذه الغارات في
محيط مستشفى الامل الى سقوط عشرات الشهداء
الى جانب مئات الجرحى نتيجه الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي المتعمد والمباشر سواء للمنازل
او محيط المستشفيات بغيه دفع الناس
واجبارهم على النزوح من هذه المنطقه
باتجاه المنطقه الجنوبيه تحديدا منطقه
ميراج الواقعه بين مدينه رفح وخان يونس او
الى داخل مدينه رفح الاوضاع هنا صعبه
للغايه حتى ان الدبابات الاسرائيليه
استهدفت في ساعه مبكره من صباح اليوم سقطت
قذيفه اطلقتها الدبابات الاسرائيليه داخل
ساحه مدرسه امام مستشفى ناصر وهي مدرسه
تابعه للمروه ما ادى الى اصابه عشره
فلسطينيين من النازحين الذين احتموا داخل
هذه المدرسه التابعه للامم المتحده لكن
نيران جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وقذائف
الصاروخيه طالتهم حتى وهم نائمين ومحتمل
داخل منشاه تابعه للامم المتحده الجميع في
دائره الاستهداف سواء المستشفيات او حتى
منازل المدنيين التي لم يطلب جيش الاحتلال
من سكانها اخلاء مناطقهم وحتى مدارس
والمؤسسات التابعه للامم المتحده الجميع
في دائره النار الاسرائيليه في هذه الحرب
التي تشنها اسرائيل على القطاع مؤمن
الشرافي من مستشفى ناصر ب خانيونس شكرا
جزيلا لك